el líder de la manada de power of the
dog olfatea la gloria de los oscar la
oscura meditación de jane campion sobre
la masculinidad tóxica y la sexualidad
prohibida ambientada en un rancho
ganadero de montana de los años 20 fue
producida por netflix
ahora aspira 12 premios de la academia
incluido el de mejor película nacida
nueva zelanda campeón hace historia como
la primera mujer en ser nominada dos
veces a mejor dirección 28 años después
de su anterior nominación por el piano
la extensa y atmosférica adaptación de
la clásica novela de ciencia ficción de
frank herbert ha conseguido 10
nominaciones aunque ninguna para el
director canadiense de nivel nerd
la adaptación de steven spielberg del
reconocido musical 'west side story'
obtuvo siete nominaciones al igual que
belfast la historia autobiográfica del
director kenneth branagh sobre su
crecimiento durante el conflicto
norirlandés convirtiendo a brennan en la
única persona en la historia de los
oscar con siete nominaciones en siete
categorías diferentes a lo largo de su
carrera a
los oscar de este año marcan la
continuación de la batalla por el
prestigio entre los estudios
tradicionales y los servicios de
streaming con dos nominaciones a la
mejor película para las producciones de
netflix y una para apple tv y aunque los
nominados representan orígenes más
diversos que las listas de 2015 y 2016
que desataron el hashtag oscar show
white las nominaciones de este año son
notablemente menos inclusivas que el año
pasado cuando 9 de las 20 nominaciones
de actuación fueron para personas de
color